you are the author when it comes to Wall
Street culture there's no one else out
there but in terms of reaction you have
never gotten such a visceral reaction in
such a short time what do you make of
all this
it does I've had one experience kind of
like this and it was when I published
Moneyball but it but in that case they
weren't threatening to throw old
baseball scouts in jail for what they
did
but the disruption to the industry that
that cause feels a lot like this and the
instigator that is a character kind of
who is taking a different view of the
industry and isn't kind of investigated
in one way or another the main character
of this book Brad Katsuyama is I got a
similar feel to me to Billy Beane so I
fit I'm the reaction feels it reminds me
of that all that that everybody has to
have an opinion about the book right
away no matter if they read the book or
not or it so that's that's similar what
is the opinion about the book or about
the claim the markets rigged that's a
big claim yeah well it is rigged so it's
not that big you reading the book I
don't think you can put it down and say
the markets not rigged yeah I really
don't think you I don't I mean the less
you we get we can we can we can parse
the word rigged
maybe we should so let me give you an
analogy I think is a very close analogy
to the way the stock market structured
it's a casino analogy ah so I have a
casino mm-hmm and I want to I want to
start a poker game in the casino
so I tell I get three card sharks and I
tell them go sit there and start the
game make it look like a good games
going on there no four is there no nines
there are no queens and the deck only
you will know that and we will pay some
tour group operators to bring like a
bunch of dumb tourists in to play with
you they won't know you tourists David
Einhorn's and dumb tourists yes in it
come on in this analogy hold on and this
now every every investor David Einhorn
did not know he did not understand he
understood that he understood that
whenever he tried to do something in the
market the market moved it like the like
they knew like someone knew what he was
up to in the same way that big pension
fund managers and usual fund managers
saw when they tried to execute big
orders oh my god it's like someone knows
I want to buy before I buy
but he didn't know why he didn't know he
didn't understand he didn't understand
that
high-frequency traders were putting
machines in exchanges to be closer to
the exchange so that they get it they
could get pricing information to
milliseconds before him and so and so
forth let me put can I finish my
absolutely so here's the analogy so uh
so of course the the tourists get
fleeced all the time in the poker game
because they don't know that the deck is
rigged right the poker players pay the
casino cut of what they make the casino
operators pivot or group the to a group
company money to bring in the tourists
so in this case casinos the exchange the
poker players are the high-frequency
traders and the tour group operators of
the banks and the brokers that handle
the stock market orders analogies pretty
close so is that Rick is that a rigged
game I think it is a rigged game
well it's rigged only in as much as
rigged so let's use your analogy why are
you so invested in the idea this is fair
why are you even arguing about this it's
so clear yeah you seem to be so why
you're actually very interesting no but
you you seem to be you can see it's very
clear that people are being front-runner
in the market there's plenty of evidence
in the book there people making their
offices among their orders are being
anticipated dissipated and run and run
in front of that's right
and while no no there's some people I
mean in all fairness I don't have a
stake in the proceedings here certainly
not like you because you're the author
of the book Michael but there are some
people right you probably met some of
them who would say in order to front run
you have to have a client way I'm sorry
in order to front run so you have a
client so and the HIV students don't
have a pliant they buy the order flow
they buy they bought they pay they pay I
mean on baby drive maybe they pay this
evening they pay no they pay for they
pay to execute the orders so they pay TD
Ameritrade tens of millions of dollars a
year
Schwab they pay e-trade so they pay for
the right to execute the orders at a
delayed price so why would you I mean
that asks that question why would it why
would anybody pay for the right to
execute someone else's stock market work
that in itself is a little curious I
mean I can understand why
if I'm a stock market investor why I'd
pay a commission to a broker handle my
order but why on top of that is the
broker turning around and selling my
order to some high-frequency trader for
the right to execute where's the value
the value in that is is is quite clear
it's that this the the that order for
the high-frequency trader is an
opportunity to exploit and it's an
opportunity to exploit because he has
advanced information about the pricing
in the stock market is that fair he's
also getting paid by the exchange to
print right to print the trade it's it's
I mean they're you're getting into a
complicated discussion because the
exchange pricing sometimes you pay and
sometimes sometimes you get paid but but
so that's a almost a separate issue it
is true that the exchanges create
incentives to be on one side of the
trade or the other and I think that
basically when you look at it at the
bottom of this is a bit like the
financial crisis at the bottom of this
is that the system is riddled with
really bad incentives I mean it doesn't
make a lot of sense for brokers to be
owning exchanges I think I mean in fact
in the exchanges are for investors not
brokers not for middlemen when the
brokers on the exchanges the exchange is
going to be essentially an instrument of
the intermediary rather than me all
right then are the exchanges sort of the
eight you know like how the rating age
what the rating agencies were in the big
short is that what the exchanges are
here in a similar sort if they weren't
for profit right would they be a better
for such force we could trust more it's
a similar sort of role it's a that
analogy is probably impotent but yes
that it occurred to me that's actually
sort of the role that they are they're
thought to be their role it's a kind of
utility role you need them to be an
honest broker you need them to create a
experience for a customer who walks onto
them and if they because they are for
profit they're incentivized and because
the way the markets work the way they
work they have to meet quarterly
earnings and so on and so forth
it's not a long term view they're taking
it's a very short-term view they're
taking that they're constantly subjected
the temptation of taking money from one
faction of their clientele
at the Institute to to put the other
faction in a bad place would we like
these hfts more if they actually were
putting money at risk if they had
positions the fact that they are just
taking a scrape here is that what we
just like them so much
the fact that they they're sort of setup
not to take bookmark at risk yeah that's
fine
I want you to have skin in the game if
you have skin in the game and you could
lose I like if you could have you know
four thousand trading days without a
single day's loss something's a little
weird right let me say anybody I think
yes right but let's rewind the clock to
pre nineteen seventy five when there
weren't really market makers the way
there are now they were you know trading
was a largely an agency business this is
before Gus levy and before the arbitrage
desk at Goldman Sachs and Robert Rubin
they didn't lose any money either you
don't lose any money as an agency trader
oh that's not it's not true that they
didn't lose anyway when they when when
you rewind the clock I mean it I mean I
worked on Wall Street the Salomon
Brothers the traders would have down
days and then have up days and they just
hope the up days were better than the
down days they were putting money they
were putting money wrist and they're
putting money at risk the position they
were taking I mean I'm not saying that
was a pure and innocent and great either
right I mean I there are different
problems in different days but but the
the the role they were playing was a
buffer in the market they were they're
playing the role of Brad Brad Cassie I'm
a player at RBC that someone needs to
sell a million shares of something and
the market won't isn't ready you know
I'll sit in them it actually I here's
one
I'll phrase it as a question instead of
making a statement would you acknowledge
that your critics perhaps are have eight
one fair point which is that it's hard
to generalize that much of what you're
talking about much of the people whom
you identify as the victims in the book
are by and large institutional traders
some of them are mutual fund managers
like okay I'll be there can I stop you
there I'm sorry but in the book there's
a long interview with the guy who spent
years selling the order flow for TD
Ameritrade mhm I mean that is not
running that's not in that's not
institutional investors that's you and
me
that's mom-and-pop any any and he says
he says what's the most valuable order
for a high-frequency trailer to exploit
it's a market
from an individual investor because the
individual investor has such such a slow
feed basically so no it's true now what
is true if the order is a hundred share
order it's probably not the big deal
it's not that big a deal that's true
but well our retail orders our hundred
shares but who manages the savings of
most people in America
it isn't people trade in hundred share
lots on the andany trader Ameritrade
that it is funds true and should be
careful be careful who you defend here
actively managed mutual funds right we
could talk about the passive ones
separately to actively managed mutual
funds on the whole do a terrible job of
overseeing Americans money right they
they fail to beat the market more than
fifty percent of the time and they
charge a fee on top of that or they do I
mean here we were gonna get down to this
but let's do it it out it's amazing how
how do you decide who to put the white
hat on I didn't put on the white hat I
didn't actually put a white hat on
mutual fund Street I hope you don't
think I just did that that but but it
doesn't help that in addition to the
ineptitude of the mutual fund managers
they have paid as tax that it's all a
cost to the ultimate investor so it's I
mean I'm not I'm not apologize for the
mutual fund industry that's not the
point the point is the out the people
whose money they're managing it's
ultimately damaged by this are in lots
of little individual investors and so
it's to say that like this doesn't touch
the individual Buster is crazy the
second reason is crazy
and this gets the Goldman Sachs's recent
involvement is that is that the in order
to preserve essentially the the stock
market system that enables this sort of
activity the level of complexity gone
through the roof and basically nobody
ends no the reason I write a book about
this nobody understands the stock market
this guy can walk in and describe a
stock market that nobody understands and
David Einhorn listens to and says oh my
god I this I did not know the complexity
is a source of instability the people at
Goldman Sachs I talked to who have
thrown their weight behind this exchange
said the main reason they did it was
that they you know the outages of these
changes in the flash crash whatever is
the various technical mishaps that
no punctuate our life of the stock
market these days they see it all a
symptomatic of a much bigger problem
there is going to they said there's
going to be a massive flash crash times
10 and we're and Goldman's going to get
blamed so we got to get out of this
before it's before before that happens
that's not good for the individual
investor either but is this still
material to the individual investors
because today when I go to execute a
stock I definitely feel like man how did
that get jacked right in front of my
face every time I do feel that way but
15 years ago when I did a trade I was
paying significantly more to do it with
a specialist because you would because
because of what the fees were so yeah so
you got to make a distinction here so
it's a different problem at different
days it really worse today than it was
when specialists are on the floor I ever
said that uh has the system always been
raped yes I mean they need different
ways in different ways no no hold on all
hold on hold on in different ways the
more the the problems then were
different from the problems today and
this is the problem that you're not
making a distinction that think is
really important to make yes technology
has brought incredible benefits to the
individual investor it's really good
that trading is computerized
I'm not against computerized trading
it's that it does not have to be
computerised scalping going on with
computerized trading there the two are
not they're not in it they're not
inextricably linked they can they're
separate things what really should
happen is that you get you get to all
the benefits of the computerized trading
without someone running in front of you
when you trade that's what should happen
and that's there's no reason that can't
happen there's no reason that can't
happen and I think part of like this is
the largest discussion about like the
state of Wall Street but what's happened
here is that technology has basically
eliminated a role Wall Street used to
play used to need a human being to bring
together a buyer and a seller you
couldn't do it yourself you couldn't now
you hit your button on your computer and
your stock market you're starving or go
in no box with everybody else's stock
market order you don't feel good about
that that's good that's good
the problem is I'm not completely but
some guy is still jacking you and that's
the problem is you've got traders who
take all this unnecessary financial
intermediation happening
Wall Street's found a way to insert
itself in the stock market where it's no
longer necessary
and there's all this trading happening
between between intermediaries and you
and me that just don't need to happen